[Música]
dicen que los ojos son el espejo del
alma yo quiero decirles hoy que nuestros
ríos son el reflejo de lo que somos de
todos nosotros yo crecí en un barrio
popular en el sur de bogotá tenía como
tres límites por un lado una avenida por
otro lado una un patio lote abandonado y
por otro costado
un vecino indeseado que nadie quería el
tóxico que todo el mundo en la espalda
el río el protagonista de esta charla
en este río se daban muchas situaciones
era un río que nos traía los malos
olores era el rival que se le atribuía
las enfermedades en el barrio el nicho
de los roedores bajaba basura pero al
mismo tiempo en este lugar se daban
nuestras aventuras de niños y de jóvenes
cuando vamos fútbol el balón caía al río
nos llevamos los dos equipos a rescatar
el balón bota vamos piedras para
llevarlo hasta la orilla eso sí lo que
hacíamos nosotros era evitar a toda
costa que salpicará agua a nuestro
cuerpo porque producía las enfermedades
transitaba así mi juventud y tuve una
oportunidad de oro gracias a mi padre
puede conocer lo que muchos llaman el
río más hermoso del mundo caño cristales
en el oriente colombiano
este es un río de colores este es un río
que no parece amarillo ni parece verde
es amarillo es verde la intensidad de
los colores se nota allí hay una planta
que se adhiere a la roca y cuando el
agua baja cuando pasa el agua brota y
forma una especie de tapete que al tacto
es demasiado suave pero además jonas
posee
como en unas mini cavernas subterráneas
acuáticas que se forman en este lugar
realmente es mágico es tan mágico que yo
recuerdo que me sentaba en algún sitio
silencioso a esperar a ver si sale una
criatura mágica un unicornio no algún
nada porque si existía en ese lugar
donde tenían que vivir que vivir qué
habitar
luego que conozco caño cristales y
vuelvo a mi barrio pues ese vecino
indeseado cds y no tóxico lo empecé a
ver de otra forma yo a mi río no lo
volví a averiguar y me hizo una pregunta
en ese entonces seguramente profunda
para la ciencia la gran incógnita la
humanidad y este río donde nace de dónde
viene este río fue la pregunta que me
hizo fuimos con varios amigos con mi
novia en ese entonces claro es mi esposa
y nos fuimos hasta donde nacía el río y
nos encontramos con el páramo más grande
del mundo el páramo de sumapaz
públicamente 5 países en el mundo tienen
este ecosistema es un lugar imagínense
lo con mucha neblina constantemente con
lluvia que el rocío de las gotas caen al
suelo las reciben las plantas y tienen
la capacidad de almacenar 40 veces su
peso en agua con qué intención regular
en los tiempos secos para que otras
fuentes hídricas puedan vivir ahí nace a
nuestro río el río tunjuelo estaba en
ese lugar y además de una gran laguna la
laguna que le permitía su vida
nos fuimos durante cuatro días
tres noches caminando siguiendo el curso
no podíamos creer en los primeros días
que no estamos bañando en el río sea
evitaba aquí abajo en mi barrio el río
me tocara pero ahí quería meterme al río
a los pozos que había levantábamos las
piedras se vean cangrejos el campesino
estaba pescando eso cuando uno es
citadino y cuando uno solamente ha
tenido esa relación con el río es
impactante el tercer día empecé a
comprender los problemas que tenía el
río en un punto que llamamos el
triángulo las bermudas habían tres
lugares tres afectaciones fuertes al río
un relleno sanitario que recibía todas
las basuras de la ciudad producía un
agua en descomposición y llegaba al río
unas curtiembres que transformaban el
cuero y el proceso industrial sus aguas
las vertían al río y unas canteras
formando el triángulo decir unas
carcasas una actividad minera que hacían
unos huecos de 30 a 40 metros y entonces
el río casi que no lo elevaban esos tres
puntos del río no lo hacían desaparecer
y cambiar en nuestra travesía seguíamos
bajando y kilómetros más adelante fuimos
a buscar el río a ver qué pasaba con él
el río ya baja en triste
lechoso negro triste y obviamente así
mismo nosotros nos sentíamos de haber
visto que ese río en el que nos habíamos
bañado había transformado
el río que bañaba que paseaba que se
circulaba alrededor de nuestro barrio
también lo hacía con muchos barrios en
su ronda eran mucho más barrios como el
nuestro que dan la espalda que no
querían ese vecino cercano
una sorpresa final cuando llegamos a su
desembocadura y es que nos encontramos
con poblaciones indígenas nos hayan
dicho que los indígenas
en la ciudad no estaban pues allí con
los abuelos en lo que ellos llaman los
círculos de la palabra nos enseñaron una
cultura que es la que aplicamos ahora
con la que trabajamos con nuestros
jóvenes que la cultura del no daño una
cultura con tres premisas que invitan un
comportamiento natural la primera
premisa es la cultura de los daños
no te hagas daño con tus manos con tu
pensamiento con tu boca no te hagas daño
pero tampoco le hagas daño a otro no
afecte había otra persona pero el tercer
pilar el que más nos interesaba nos
llama la atención es el que tenía que
ver con el que no permitas que se haga
daño nuestro río siempre hemos dado la
espalda nuestros ríos nos interesaba
quien en ese vecino y a nuestro río lo
habíamos afectado precisamente por la
acción el comportamiento que teníamos
cuando estuvimos en sumapaz llegó a
nosotros otra historia de otro río que
quise ir a indagar a averiguar
se trata del cañón del río duda el
corredor estratégico de la guerrilla es
el lugar donde durante 60 años no había
podido pasar los civiles solamente los
actores armados y los campesinos que
allí vivían una oportunidad nuevamente
de oro de estar en la habana en los
diálogos de paz en cuba y allí con esos
comandantes le decía que quería ir a
atravesar el cañón del río duda ese
corredor que había sido el control
militar por parte de ellos me dio los
detalles regreso al país algunas
coordinaciones para permitir con
comunidad y con autoridades empezar la
travesía que esta vez se trata de siete
días y por primera vez en 60 años una
expedición de personas que iban a mirar
qué estaba pasando con esta parte de
colombia un primer día de casi 11 12
horas de caminata nos recibió una
escuela con cinco niños y un maestro la
labor de la educación de entrega en este
lugar el segundo día en el centro
poblado varias familias nos narraban las
historias de la guerra de los conflictos
pero además de los niños que habían
nacido
criado y que luego fueron los grandes
dirigentes y los que coordinaban las
guerrillas en este lugar el tercer
cuarto y quinto día no encontramos
población únicamente eran casas
abandonadas que antes fueron los grandes
centros operativos de la guerrilla y el
sexto día de nuevo casi que igual que el
río tunjuelo nos recibían a nosotros las
comunidades indígenas recortaba con esas
comunidades indígenas las palabras que
nos daban en su círculo y allí reiteraba
algo que enseñaban y es que las
generaciones del futuro cuando nos
preguntan rápidamente respondemos son
los niños pues los abuelos deseando las
generaciones futuro son las que van
adelante y adelante van nuestros abuelos
las del pasado vienen atrás y atrás
vienen nuestros niños con esas
enseñanzas cada vez que visita un río
impregnado en lo que me permitía y lo
que ganaba en mí hice
una travesía y navegue el río amazonas
esta vez durante varios días inmerso en
el amazonas entendí la pequeñez que
somos como seres humanos
pero la entendí frente a la
majestuosidad frente a la inmensidad del
río allí fue cuando vi que somos parte
de
somos parte de hay una trama de la vida
en que nosotros somos uno más no somos
el centro de lo que está pasando en el
planeta somos uno más también puede ir
al río atrato en el pacífico y en el
pacífico su cultura las cantoras los
bailes de nuestros niños indígenas de
nuestros niños afro esa cultura anfibia
impregna miro sentido de pertenencia y
de arraigo con los ríos empecé a
entender cuál era mi propósito volvía a
mi río tunjuelo y sobre ese río en el
sur de la ciudad
generaba mis acciones todas estas
experiencias generan dos aprendizajes
puntuales que han marcado mi vida
el primero los ríos fluyen hasta el
ministerio el asunto es entender cuando
el río fluye cuando el río va recibiendo
los otros las otras quebradas los
afluentes se va convirtiendo en lo que
recibe el río es la esencia de lo que
recibe el río recibe aguas sucias
contaminadas pero también recibe aguas
limpias
a nosotros nos han insistido que las
personas tóxicas que ese vecino
indeseado como el río tunjuelo nuestro
barrio hay que evitarlos pues no vi el
primer río que cuando llegara el agua
sucia desviará y no quisiera recibirlo
lo recibía lo que encontré en los ríos
es que había una fuente permanente que
hacía que el río pudiera autodepurarse
el río recibe la carga contaminante pero
kilómetros más adelante lo poder se
puede recuperar yo creo que tenemos
capacidad nosotros de encontrar nuestra
fuente para poder auto depurar y
recuperar así como insistimos y buscamos
cómo conectar nuestros dispositivos y
tenerlos full de batería muy bien
cargados necesariamente que buscar
nuestra fuente para entender de dónde es
que tenemos las fuerzas para todos los
días fluir como también lo hace el río y
una segunda de las enseñanzas de todas
esas experiencias con los ríos es que en
torno a un río encontré mi propósito
respondí esa pregunta que constantemente
nos hacemos y él para quien la puede
responder respondí para que quería estar
acá cuando conocí caño cristales y ha
convencido que hace el astronauta ya
conocer el espacio sideral respondí que
quiere a conocer el planeta dónde vivía
ese para qué y verme reflejado en el río
entender que lo que veo en el río es lo
que somos todos nosotros entender que si
el río está contaminado seguramente las
personas que están allí tienen
afectaciones y complicaciones entender
que ese río tiene muchas obras grises y
civiles pero puede estar limpio es un
río que posiblemente no tiene una
calidez en las relaciones humanas en su
gente entender que si está limpio ya
dice comparte muy posiblemente hay
calidad de vida en la gente que circunda
si hiciera la pregunta de cuál es tu
marca celular de cuál es tu barrio de
cuáles es el lugar donde compras tus
vestidos el restaurante favorito
seguramente las respuestas son
inmediatas las tenemos nosotros con toda
claridad pero si yo pudiera preguntar
hoy cuál es el lugar con el que tú
tienes ese sentido de pertenencia
el arraigo las acciones de lucha de
resistencia con el que te sientes parte
de posiblemente tuvimos un poco más
quiero invitarlos a que nuestras manos
se junten por un momento unirlas por el
borde interno el borde interno que
tenemos imaginen que ahí donde se unen
nuestras manos está el río principal
nuestros dedos la palma es la cuenca que
contiene el río aquí está la gente las
ciudades el campo las montañas los
valles se contienen aquí en nuestras
palmas y en este río
lo que debemos y quisiéramos nosotros
reiterar en lo que quiero insistir
viéndonos nosotros reflejados en esta
cuenca y en este río es si podemos
responder rápidamente como respondemos
cuáles son nuestros almacenes nuestros
celulares nuestros barrios la posible a
entender el lugar donde tengo
pertenencia y responder a la pregunta de
cuál es su río
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]